welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
we're rolling and it's it's funny that
you mentioned that our very special
guest today is the delightful and
tremendously I hope you still feel that
way okay I'm delightful and just just
has an absolutely I would say a
tremendously tempting tour so dr. drew
the body
Pinsky many years ago we got a peek
behind the curtain of your upper body
and I gotta say that was long time ago
you mask that on you deliberately do
that don't you on TV he's told rim not
anymore
seeing him and I was like what and
excited seen you for a while and TV now
then I see you shirtless at a pool and
I'm like what the fuck this guy once
about a towel on my waist or something
had just had my upper body I mean
something a long time ago weightlifting
yeah long time ago I was 14 and you'd
say you'd have almost never stopped yeah
it's weird
but now it's become my like my
meditation now I get weightlifting I
dunno well it's time away verily
weightlifting anymore but it's it's I
left I listen to podcast and I just sit
and I just go into a like a meditative
state and does your wife talk during
this we're huge fans of you doctor this
is in oh wait Tom and I were living in
the rampart division we were engaged we
a twin a one-bedroom apartment but
Celebrity Rehab was the glue to our
marriage
we've seen every episode we were
obsessed you I've listened to you since
love lines since the poor man days
that's kind of weird k-rock 13 so one
thing that stood out the most is that it
really felt like nobody would know that
you were this in shape dude which is
kind of like an interesting thing a lot
of people that are really into fitness
yeah would like make an effort to go
like I'm going to show everybody know
and and I'm going to show them because
I've earned it which then you go like oh
yeah that's good
but I feel like none of the clothes you
wear on Celebrity Rehab or any no no
because it takes away from you no say
you took credibility and you be a we're
early on in my career as a physician I
always thought that'd be kind of weird
yeah I remember I used to wear green
sometimes in people so did you where did
you have to shop for like oversized
shirts that was that party no but I
always had problem with shoulder and arm
fit I've always said it's just how I'm
constructed yeah and if I whale if this
stuff gets big here yeah that Mariners
going to is that's that doctor arms I
thought oh that's weird okay so you
saying you wore green greens you know
surgical greens
oh and you were you looked excuse-me
Ripton I didn't look like a rest
everybody else sounds like that's weird
I feel like after I mean a prize I'm
probably the one just out of you but I
think for the audience you're gonna have
to post some some thirst-trapping-- ten
pounds first my wives my we were Mexico
last week and my wife posted a picture
of the two of us in a Bay this she she's
Bionic she has some insane genes it's
all just natural with her and the god
bless her and her bless her heart as
they say bless your heart
and for God's sake at least make me sit
up I look like I'm like I look like a
heart like a mess or something we have a
long-standing thing where it's like you
take a picture of me I'm reviewing you
get last look over the outfit and make
sure he doesn't look homeless or weird
good yeah yeah you need that yeah you
don't know you got make sure somebody
loves you that's that's what we say when
we say it's that guy out there that's
dressed all fucked up it's because the
wife doesn't love it there we go someone
doesn't love you man yeah you need love
in your life you guys so drew how did
you get into being this like celebrity I
don't want say celebrity doctor but yeah
it's weird
I'll tell you though off to tell the
long story but we you know we were
talking about Stern before we yeah
you're going on Stern this week well no
the wrap up show the wrap up show which
is that which is these days equally as
in a
I've said in the real seat and the
Howard interview see and that's reserved
now for like Gwyneth Paltrow yeah no one
gets in there a list yeah but when I was
in there I will tell you it's an very
interesting seat to sit in because he
it's like it's like he hypnotizes you
like you're in a truth serum
he just got to go with him and just got
to become abject honesty and he just is
this amazing way of just just getting in
today follows his nose it's from all his
small therapy and stuff and all his all
the trig exam but I was this the story I
wanted to tell you I was my mother just
died whistling I should very advanced
age not know no certain life should be
celebrated when people you know they
live in your night and you've had a good
life no it was fine everything is fine
but I was cleaning up her basement I
found a stack of my old mad magazines
1968 to 1972 a whole cache of them and I
thought oh my god Howard loves these
things I bet he'd love this so I went I
wrapped it up in butcher paper and I
went got bought a car never a handle it
note and I gave it to him and I was just
totally crestfallen when when the next
day on the radio he was just going off
about why would somebody send anyone
this piece of shit my used toilet paper
he went out for 20 minutes about and
then it came up again today
he went off again today because it
stopped apparently I brought it up with
Corolla I'm dad I'm Andrew podcast and
and I told I was you know I was looking
forward to him hearing that hearing that
he liked this gift and I just just it's
something pretty bad of course it
wouldn't be good radio if it didn't
sting right it had to be real and he
would have been a mention became a 20
minute bit that's his genius right right
but it's stung today it's still stung it
so Adam called that came up on the radio
today so there you go now I'm going to
Gary was talking about the area that
sent me a note it is Gary something you
know that tonight he got a text from
somebody demanding an apology claiming
to be me and I was like Gary no no no no
a million miles from that hurt though if
it didn't hurt I also know yes I was I
was crestfallen I was disappointed but
then I thought to myself if didn't sting
this would not have been good radio
just has to be that kind of truth you
really you really just wanted him to be
like I really twine you moment but then
again it wouldn't be Howard Stern if he
wouldn't take something awesome and make
it an erotic funny absolutely in here
and Gary just goes I sent him an email
goes welcome to my world
yeah because no good deed goes
unpunished every little thing he's like
I thought you'd like that
yeah yeah that's the best cuz on that
show they're always talking about it's
the only place where if you do something
good it gets turned in all areas okay
text me Wow Gary someone pretending to
be you demanding an apology that's crazy
that's crazy that's crazy so the long
story is crazy talk
the long story is I let's see I think
you take it all the way back I was a
third-year medical fourth year medical
student and I would hear in in Pasadena
living a less than a block from what was
then k-rock and week a rock back in the
day when you were 13 that was this
little shithole over like a dental
office it was really a horrible players
like I should I wish we'd take him video
and stuff of it because it was like
never will be recreated this this kind
of an environment and there dude they're
kind of working on a documentary on her
right now so okay yeah and they're
viewing everybody and I'm Rodney being
in hi Ron of course and so so I was I
would just I was really getting
frustrated with music and people started
talking about the station and I what's
up the street how interesting I started
listening and again I got kind of
excited about it people I knew that
lived nearby we're starting to go over
there new people and this guy calls me
that it was hanging out over there he
goes hey they got the show in the middle
of the night apparently two guys were
just taking calls about relationships
and their program director told them
they need to make it a community service
show right they needed to make because
they do service hours so they gave them
midnight Sunday night to 3 a.m. Monday
morning fantastic yeah and but then
they're trying to figure out making me a
service and my friend I guess suggested
me or I'm in medical school so maybe I
could and they call me and they go hey
what do i do I want you do a segment
called ask a surgeon you use big words
they'll be really fun
so they finally long story they got me
in there brought my textbooks I might
gynecology tax my infectious disease
textbook idler carried textbooks up
there really not having any idea what I
was getting into but I was freaked out
and lo and behold I heard these just
amazing things coming being presented to
was the poor man and the Swedish Eagle
in the middle of the night and Scott
Mason Tammy
sweetie she was still around yeah it's
only serious and I thought I should I
should come back and and what's tucked
out what really stunned me was I was
dealing with a lot of AIDS patients that
and continued to the next five years
think tons of AIDS work and no one was
talking to young people about it we'd
just been to the sexual revolution
well the adults the perpetrator that
never contemplated that adolescence was
engaged in sexuality sure condoms were
behind the counter yet ask the
pharmacist for them the term safe sex
hadn't been coined yet people were not
talking to adults young adults about
this at all yeah about was gonna I was
like dude so I was 24 I was like hey I
know what 19 9 year olds are up 80 90
girls are up to we got it we got talked
about this and no one had ever heard in
fact we just were transitioning from
calling it grids to eight we were yeah
we're calling it aids that but we
weren't calling it we hadn't identified
the virus yet wow we had we had just
we're getting htlv three remember that
she'll be three did you suggest talking
about this on the air is that no they
came to him they came to him and so I
just came in there as to do a man right
for man an eagle and I was like oh my
god this is like I gotta keep coming
back and this is a hangout so I'd sort
of hang out in the hall and if something
came up or if I was not calling crazy
and I'd stay there for like midnight to
2:00 or something hanging around finally
I was started sitting at the table with
them and being a part of it and it was
it was became apparent to me early that
it was a two-man thing like yeah sort of
a parent-child kind of conflict thing or
funny and straight yeah and and I just
thought it was important and I have for
10 years I was doing what I thought was
one night a week community service
really I thought it was just interesting
I it was like my social hour I
interesting people we'd have guests in
there and it was just interesting and
fun met my wife through there so yeah
yeah and and after 10 years of doing it
one night a week 10 years yeah
yeah that's yeah for free maybe for free
they put it on five nights a week
because I remember what what happened
was I remember what they know they got a
rate we they moved it to like ten to one
at that point because they kept people
get out of buzz around late cuz it was
sexual Kanye ten years I mean you had
finished your internship and residency
yeah oh yeah practicing and stuff what
kind of general medicine but I was also
doing at that point I mean think about
this eighty late 80s I was doing running
the medical services in a psychiatric
hospital so I was also doing I was doing
an acute care inpatient thing I was
doing medical services psychiatric
hospital and then are now patient
medical deal and how much it was a lot I
was way and I'm like I have to podcast
like sick workaholics like that bad bad
bad and in 91 so now it was I guess was
eight years now so is eight years of
five nine ten that's one night away they
they got a rating book on this show they
don't do none awaiting the book normally
a to ask for it or pay for it and I've
never forget this we got a twenty eight
share what why this is like it's that
good I don't know anything this in a
market where if you get a point three
you're doing great and I never I called
the program director I go look I'm I
really know much about this but I think
we're all participating in something
here
yeah I don't really know but twenty it
seems like crazy to me goes and I'll
never forget this it was Tripp Reeve who
was the Gerald manager Carrick he goes
because I need balls I put this on five
nights a week that's what I'm gonna do
him I put it on five minutes because I
thought oh because I you know I was I
was working from 5:00 in the morning to
10:00 at night at that point and and
Susan immediately then got pregnant with
triplets triplets yeah and so she goes
she goes if you're out five minutes a
week it's not community service anymore
you got to get pay hell yeah if she set
me and say somebody love me sent me in
and I've hat in hand what could you
please can I please get paid I can't you
were having kids stuff yeah and that's
where it all got started
now is that first opera and I don't
imagine it's gonna be crazy but like was
it a decent
or $50 or show it what 9191 yeah yeah
and but but they sort of promise like
we'll have a real contract if this goes
clear how long did you stay a $50 it
didn't seem that long because then it
got syndicated so I'm starting to get
paid a little bit a little bit okay and
then in 95 these television producers
turned out that I was doing with riki
rachtman then yeah and these and they
were like was a TV show like I I don't
know interesting it's all it was all
kind of an exploration for me it's like
I still thought I was doing kind of a
community service because there was
nowhere for it to talk to kids about
this stuff and I thought there was just
so much encouragement of bad unhealthy
behavior I thought well we're just gonna
be here and be this advocate for decent
behavior and there's a long story there
too but eventually Ricky found out he
couldn't make a deal with them and they
turned to me and they go who do you want
to do with this and I was like I have no
idea I'm fine just leave me alone to
practice medicine if you really wanted I
can do this on Friday afternoon at
Saturday afternoon that's it
otherwise leave me alone and I went out
running one day and I'm I was in a spike
over the spot where it was when I
thought God but that guy that does mr.
Bertram in the morning could do this we
had met once before and I thought that
guy can do it so they how much there's
many details to get into all this but
they brought him out they tested us
everyone seemed to like it
put us in a makeup booth and they go you
guys work out your relationship will
start filming in an hour
and we're like nine hours the pilot for
love line that ended up on MTV which by
the way at that point was a Fox show
long story there - it got canceled and
then picked up by MTV well I'm TV was I
think a decent home for because of the
subject matter I think and about one
once a memory I have about that first
day of filming the pilot is our stage
manager Tracy came up to who she became
our stage manager we went did it for
like five years and Angela your partner
there what was with Adam it was the TV
now some TV yeah he hadn't even started
the radio yet we were just doing tests
doing this podcast is pilot for the TV
show and he stood we started in the TV
show before he came over to radio yeah
and and Terry Stu goes how many years
you guys
working together we looked each other
when we met this morning yeah and I
thought oh that must mean something
significant I think that probably I
always wondered this like without like
knowing you know so much about the show
but you being a doctor and having to you
know think about the advice you're
giving out way out whether it's being
like healthy and and you know ethically
right did you ever have those like
moments even though you know it's
entertainment where somebody asked
something and Adam being comedic gives
advice you're like you cannot miss it
constantly what I mean like not just in
like hey no that's the bad about I mean
like where you get serious about it we
yeah it was not so much without because
II really had a pretty good instinct of
things but Ricky and for Matt more and
more that and I actually gotten of
almost in a almost in a violent fight
with Jon Favreau over this he was in
Fabri unfairly director the director he
had just done the swingers right it
wasn't
yeah that's right and he was the guest
on Loveline the TV show and this guy
calls in and he was clearly
schizophrenic and dangerously psychotic
and like in danger of self harm or
harming other people and complaining
about in a paranoid way about people who
try to make him take his medication than
Favreau goes don't tell don't let
anybody tell you what to do do not think
those medicines and I went whoa whoa you
got to stop this is dangerous this guy's
actually sick who do you think you are
I'm like oh dude don't go there when
you're talking to a sick person yeah and
we got into it and yes I said I want to
see I don't know what's that and then I
so we would film show up to show after
show we didn't know anybody we'd sure
six shows a day out of my exchange
another and and the next show I had a
panic attack and and I had to leave the
stage because I was like I didn't ride
because I was still upset from this
fight well from that rabbit and Adam
comes into my dressing room he goes hey
get the fuck get back out there if I've
spend one more minute in this goddamn
studio that I have to because of you I'm
gonna kick your ass in there he's like
and ever since then he's like you see I
cured your panic attacks
well that show Loveline there I mean the
early the radio show taught me
everything about what you have anywhere
else to go and yeah and my mind idea was
the the same in addition to being
wanting to talk about aids and things
like that my naive notion at 24 when I
started doing was is I wish I had if I
had had something like this if I knew
somebody with this fund of knowledge
that I know how I have now have what
would I wanted to know and I retained
that sort of naive posture for about
most of the way run through the run of
that they got a little more involved
once towards the end of the 90s people
were kind of more sophisticated I think
they were getting information from
different sources and things and and
then the internet just that's the end of
it it is even that in entertainment
because you live out here you're
involved entertainment and you also know
so much about you know mental health is
are are they're more like actors and
comics of whatnot that are prone to so
healthy yeah so so so I told you I ran
the psychiatric medical service well
then I transition over to running their
addiction services and I really a lot of
my time was spent doing running an
addiction unit for 91 to 2011
essentially so 20 years I ran a drug
unit I used to hang out there for a long
time before I started running it because
and that's how I sort of learned about
it and stuff so about 25 years of
addiction medicine and slubby rehab came
out of just somebody and a really good
producer named John Irwin just came to
me and said you want to do this I'm like
wow what a great would this be really
great teach me about this yeah but this
cannot be done it's just not possible
you're kidding yourself and he went to
the hospitals and they've looked him
like she gotta be nuts and we finally
figured out I I figured out a way you
could do it which I took my team and I
put them under residential facility I
knew the director there and he wanted to
do it as a long story but in the course
of all this a professor at SC and the
Business School is actually a behavioral
economist specialist and I put together
a questionnaire he was interested in
sort of the business of entertainment
and I know he and I had a conversation
what he's my neighbor and I said when
you really should understand the people
that are the product the people that are
the the celebrities and the matches and
I said in
all sick I know they are because I talk
to him every night and they have an
inordinately Oh to have had trauma and
other things and he goes well let's test
that because it was not published
anywhere so we sort of figured out a way
to do that we use something called a
narcissistic personality inventory and
everybody that came on loved one felt
went out for two years yeah and so we so
we collected 250 profiles on people and
it was you know significant celebrities
and really a good mix of reality
comedians and musicians and things and
we analyzed all have malignant person oh
well the Melinda was the female reality
show group they were loud mallika
personality rare that's our next study
frankly because we know it's gonna be
the same comics had more trauma
musicians had more substance right
edition yeah and and we were able to
show that overall somebody who pursued
being a celebrity was more likely to
have narcissistic personality traits and
narcissistic injury and trauma and
subsidies till we sort of we didn't
publish that day we just published the
narcissism thing and it became
international press it became it was
probably spread all over the world we
end up writing a book about it called
the mirror effect and so yes the point
is somebody gotta look up this book now
it's called the mirror of fact and
someone that I mean it's very you know
we wrote in such a way it was up for
general something of this industry that
we're in there participate in yeah as in
large part like you know it is like the
the thing we wanted to do we we do it we
do it for a living we enjoy doing it
yeah but part of me always goes like
this
overall might not be the healthiest well
business to be in we were able to show
that it was a bid to solve those traumas
we really the connection between these
talking to my therapist yeah and so it's
a bid to solve it's it's it's supposed
to fill our emptiness supposed to fill
was that wrong inside and of course it
it works every time works when you're up
on stage and it doesn't work and then
the other thing my dad
wassup to me about like oh no no but
he'll you know his outside observation
yeah especially when like when was that
when when is when uh there's like a
suicide or you know overdose or
something like that he'll be like you
know he always talks about how you know
it's such a struggle to make it in this
business
yeah but he's like man the struggle once
you've made it has to be right so so we
started looking at all that and you
gotta remember you know some people you
know people that become say actors and
say I have no discernible skill of than
kind of acting and they put it all on
this yes you're willing to risk it all
to be celebrity it's like that's a
pretty heavy bad yeah big that and they
don't back it up with any other training
or any other disciplines or work or they
just I'm gonna be this and that's that
it sounds really dumb when you break it
right yeah and we also able to show that
celebrities that had skills were less
narcissistic so like a cello player
pianos craft not but I guess a
professional crap journalist could sell
it on the street that's right that's
right we were able to show that so in
again the reality shows the worst
there's no crap hey man it's me that's
its it just me you can smooth away now
alright that's no psychological training
you can pick that up reality that whole
group came on our on Loveline the TV
show you were part of that I wish but no
I'm sorry but but the other thing is it
doesn't fix the emptiness and it also
exposes the people to shame because
there's a disconnect between the
adulation that they're getting from the
outside of how they feel on the inside
and then they're fearful that people are
going to see that inside stuff that then
if they are really famous they have a
group around them that insulates them
from consequence we talked about this
all the time yeah and so so they don't
get more addiction than anybody else
well they do a little bit more but per
our data but they are not worse addicts
is just it spirals out further because
there's no one there to bring them back
is there any because I was thinking how
unnatural it is to become
a really big celebrity yeah is if you
think about anything else think about
that they have no other job really I
know and also you have a reality real
wait when you see super super
celebrities like there's almost always
these weird personality traits that you
see in quirks you know like the Michael
Jackson's where you're like Jesus Christ
but you also can't wrap your head around
how famous that yeah is I wonder if
there's any healthy way to approach
prepare yourself
not really prepared because most people
aren't going to have it but like how to
deal with that level of celebrity it
just seems like it's so most people that
I've met that are semi sane had some
other career before really yeah making
it later seems to be a health han later
yeah well I'm teaming thinking of like
Tom Jones and Julio Iglesias oh when you
meet them they just go hey man I was
just a soccer player and then all of a
sudden this weird thing happened to me
it's like but I'm still that just that
guy like playing soccer and I like
saying it's good and look there's
bewildered as anybody yeah as opposed to
hey man this is me this is what it's
which is a different thing dangerous
identify we talked about to would like
with comedy really the best comics in
the world are like at least forty and
usually late 40s mhm
and I think it's a much healthier
example for comics to see that like
because it doesn't happen usually at 20
- you know Eddie Murphy yeah but like
basically comics work for a long long
time I think that prepares a lot of them
for that exposure yeah more grounded
yeah it's a discipline you bet you've
been serve a board serving a cup and
you're also treated like shit for so
many years it actually is quite hard to
get a great ego from comedy it's very
humbling yeah yeah you can be Seinfeld
but you're working on that new hour
you're gonna eat shit after five minutes
so it's this constant thing of suffering
really built understand it which is
great which is a it's it's more like
blue-collar yeah amongst entertainment
yeah yeah but it's also the new rock
star in a weird way five years ago yeah
it's been like it's been very
interesting even though the Millennials
are screwing that up yeah well let's I
I'd like to talk to you about that too
our president is antisocial oh my god I
think it's just straight-up narcissism
yeah we have so many people we'd like
you to analyze but I you know it's
politics to me and and even just
questions about what are the right and
wrong ways for yeah I'm at the function
stuff to me is so fantastically complex
I know it's hubristic to think I would
know the right thing I started worrying
about Trump and I said anything okay
well where else we seen guys like this
okay well Andrew Jackson for sure very
much is he fuckin Andrew Jackson was
Yosemite Sam I mean he was her you read
anything about him he was nuts yeah and
it worked out okay and that's a good for
some of the Indians in the you know
southern area but it worked for the
country worked out okay and I thought oh
my god Teddy Roosevelt was a malignant
narcissist as he and bipolars hell owe
me the he never took a meeting sitting
down you have fallen through the park or
he marched through a park and climb
Hills the stuff and it's he would
everything was outdoors and moving and
shit and I thought well then he's my
favorite president so I don't know in
our system I pull er is good bad hell I
don't know
that's scary it's interesting I am I I
didn't consider this as a kid you know
as a kid presidents are just kind of
like yeah odds yeah but as I became an
adult I remember one time this
conversation about presidents and
personalities came up and somebody said
something along the lines of can you
imagine the ego you would need just to
run I do that I primer it's thinking
about that and and that having that
having one of those like AHA effects
where I was like yeah Jesus I've never
considered that that they all have to be
pretty absolutely don't you need a
personality maybe Jimmy Jimmy Carter not
and right he didn't work it works a good
yeah then work so well in office you
have ready to really think you're the
shit yeah and I have a weird
preoccupation with reading presidential
biographies uh-huh because I just one
day I did some what kind of epiphany I
was looking at the penny going hey kinda
pennies not just a profile as a person
yeah and I know something about how
people work right now what happened to
that guy's childhood I need to know I
started reading I read like 20 Clinton
Lincoln biographies and
grants biography right now sure knows
new things so good
so I wasn't linking severely depressive
well there's an interesting wrinkle on
that yes he was he was sort of bipolar
maybe - but but he really an interesting
wrinkle it finally started making sense
to me because I yes all kind of fit
together my head the way I know how
people are - I keep jumping at it so so
a guy who wrote a wrote a book called
the Lincoln marriage discovered a whole
trove of of letter correspondences
between Abraham Lincoln and a doctor in
Springfield who he started seeing before
he married Mary Todd and he found all
these letters were Lincoln was convinced
he had syphilis I think that's why he
broke off the first engagement Mary Todd
he saw a prostitute she can't give it
there's all this sir but he went by the
river and as that's where the
prostitutes hung out and became a
convinced he had syphilis dropped the
marriage with Mary Todd this doctor and
letters reassured him take this mercury
you'll be fine you can go ahead give her
Curie mercury is how they treated to
inspect they treated a lot of things
well and and there's all this
correspondence going all the way to the
White House he remains on the mercury
most of the way through his presidency
do you know what the main side effect of
mercury is depression
oh yeah it's severe vegetative
depressions is a story of him pulling
Willie I think was Willie or tad down
the street in a wagon down Pennsylvania
Avenue and they said he they found him
at the at the Capitol building still
dragging the wagon upside down with tad
like a mile up the street what yeah yeah
he was just going these vegetative
different things by the way that I feel
like severely suicidal 1.2 days they
what's the kusik I used to sleep in the
same bed with forget his name he had to
go why I had put on watch with him Wow
another thing that I think you know I've
always heard about and obviously you get
informed with these things you know
little by little and more and more but
especially since podcasts yeah and you
start to hear from fans and B is I can't
get over how at least it appears to be
how many people suffer from depression
oh it's not I mean 50 percent of us have
some sort of diagnosable yeah so hi very
common at least in a lifetime will
happen to Preston I had to president ID
severe I kind of probably have a
tendency towards it I'd panic and
anxiety disorder I don't like yeah well
shit in college terribly and look at you
you're successful okay you can go on
despite these things they're treatable
but I'm fearing now finally and I was a
real advocate for this forever but now
I'm thinking we've over medicalised it
we've overdone it now we're where you're
not allowed to solve these problems
through living and ordinary misery is no
longer an acceptable component of life
right can a smile all the time right be
happy
Sigmund Freud when he arrived on this
continent was asked a question dr. Freud
what do you expect to accomplish here
and the I said well I hope to be able to
finally distinguish it between true
mental illness and ordinary misery
that's a great quote because we're
miseries is part of a live art of living
yeah and we just we just don't tolerate
that you should somber and said there's
loss there's misery there's anxiety shit
that stress life is stressful it is part
of living but I mean I I meant to say
like when I brought just that like the I
guess the amount the frequency with
which it occurs the the number of people
that suffer from it from podcast I swear
I see so many messages that say like you
know I suffer from depression but like I
I find some relief
in listening to podcast great all that
that's great yeah that's a I'd rather
they do that to take a medication yeah
if you can do with that that's that's
overcoming coordinated that's being you
know just depressive that's not a major
depressive episode you know and again
people I think are not schooled on the
fact that they should expect to feel
yeah you know I think exactly that life
is suffering a lot what I do feel like
European thing too it's like we suffer
we suffer they take great pride look up
Hungarian insults never eat and death is
upon us
but we also party and we love and we
emotion to make for the best porn
Western Europe comes out hungry that is
their that's their main exports that's
the pair of support my checks did that
is check check girls will come over
Aryan honey's my tribe yeah kind of game
we want to play okay so we have some
like classic we play a lot of usually we
have a lot of maybe down the show intro
we'll just play it at the top okay our
ants param we play video and audio clips
from all over the internet people submit
send in like you know watch it's like
just some some content to basically
address okay well we were hoping that
you would maybe take a swing at is do
you think the person involved in the
clip is uh is taking drugs or is it one
of you two no it's not okay
or perhaps mentally ill okay perhaps
both what do I think is going on here
yeah why do I think's going on here
that's the segment that's before you
have sex if you want to be horny for two
or three hours like you've never been in
your life you have access to marijuana
to good weed listen to me
true weed alone can get you really
hornier the normal but it's been on
drill take about 10-12 been intro before
you want to have your sexual fun with
your partner or whatever you do
masturbate alright so what do you think
so I'm just looking at the environment
around him exactly living in Versailles
there's there's there's like he's
sitting in an old sort of angry grandpa
recline and he looks like a young
version of anger
he has some COPD and if you see if you
could see his upper chest
yeah he was using his accessory muscles
to breathe which mean he's got some
chronic lung disease when he takes this
balloon which I imagine his nitrous
oxide I feel like you have Steven Seagal
ability he does his pupils blow if you
can do that and he's also got stair
which means you see the white above the
IRS so this is always when you see the
white you know this this when you see
white above huh that's drugs or
hyperthyroidism it's but the only two
things will do that with meth being the
probable cause so this dude with tobacco
problem because he's got emphysema
how does 10 to 12 benadryl affect
somebody is that it makes you agitated
that actually goes the other way
it could be it could delay ejaculation
which is what he's talking about
yeah I don't think he really understands
what he's talking about but that's what
he's dog would you recommend somebody
taking I would not recommend it because
you get something called anticholinergic
delirium from that where you really can
get very like delirious you get really
well I'm so the weirdest psychosis I've
seen a botanical anticholinergic
delirium from drug overdoses really I
mean they just get like they just get
why and that could wait what's the
anticholinergic side effect what is a
Nicola it's it's what antihistamines do
in high dose cholinergic system display
so it's anticholinergic and it's it's a
really serious side effect I mean you
can get sick so you're gonna get we
would never want to label anyone
alleged I don't know this guy I don't
know that about him but he put this
video up and I'm just analyzing when I
send in your I'm just guessing the
opinion there's a probability that maybe
drugs are involved yeah now will 10 to
12 benadryl it'll make you agitated
which I imagine to I thought which helps
and so you know people think because to
banjo makes me more tired maybe three
makes him four and you get about four
and you're getting
I get I get exploding head from 250
milligrams where stuff gives me a panic
exploding head syndrome you murdered
exploded exploding head is your urine
you're asleep and all of a sudden you
get like this exploding sound and it
wakes you up like somebody knocked you
on the head really the weirdest thing
yeah it's called explode again I totally
killing me sorry but I really thought
you were talking about your dick when
you said about an hour later when you
feel it just kickin and smoke your weed
down Oh
weed is the least of my concerns what is
the what is the deal with weed like deal
well here's the thing I mean like you
know we we grew up in this era of like I
mean when we were kids it was like you
know you better watch out right the DARE
program still Schedule one people go to
prison along as a bizarre it's a bizarre
zone but then you go you know like I'm
saying like in the in recent years you
had this whole medical yeah you know
movement unfortunately a sham I'd rather
just be legalized and then now
recreational has been involved coming so
you so you there's no medical value no
there's some there some but but with
that whole sham with like yeah yeah
everybody's gotta have a page in the
last eight years of my career I never
cheated a single patient without a
marijuana prescription so no one you
know and you go and they don't ask you
if you have addiction of a treated for
addiction before they're just peers your
marijuana prescription and so that's bad
medicine I just I just care that it's
bad medicine I don't care that this
medical marijuana it has some utility
for some people I've recommended it for
people I just recommended it last week
for someone I'd much rather see somebody
on pot then then opiates sure much yeah
and and I think our laws are insane
alright yeah you know alcohol and
tobacco are good right really good LSD
should never be touched by human hands
like what it clearly has clinical
utility I mean the end of life LSD may
be very useful and cannabis is just
cannabis I mean why is that one there be
there will be problems and Colorado is
sort of founding and finding its way
through that
but problems in terms of also just
significant problems adolescents gay
people getting struck getting addicted
here and there people having an untoward
side effects from it from not very
common but I've treated a lot of it a
lot is very difficult to treat is it
more is it a psychological they know the
addiction is either you can stop her
here's an addiction it's a biological
disorder of the brain where you cannot
stop right so if you can't stop you're
addicted if you can't stop you have an
addict you're an addict if you can stop
you're either not an addict or earlier
in your disease process where you still
have control please get control over it
don't let it get out of control okay so
you'd like you can also spot somebody in
during going down that path sure there's
because addiction is a spectrum disorder
from you know predisposed to incipient
mild moderate severe and then end stage
yeah cuz it's interesting like with I
mean I think we see it most probably
most people are familiar with like
alcoholism yeah alcohol I think it's a
little clearer yeah
alcohol has the unfortunate other
category of the the binge intermittent
alcoholic which is kind of a weird
category that yeah Bert Bert I'm not
sure it's even intermittent anymore but
but he's he has over October and all
well I was competing with him and he was
very concerned that plane rides would be
difficult yeah you know I know because
he's in that more earlier stages of it
he's not out of control I didn't say
earlier yeah can I ask you something why
is why did I consider alcoholism a
disease it wouldn't be stopped it will
yeah so so what is the disease you need
to define disease first before you know
I'll check the camera for here so you
you have to define disease and then
decide notice this particular condition
or disorder meet criteria for disease so
have anacs-- well what's cancer it's
when the cells go nutty and gay so it's
an abnormal physiology cells going but
you can't will yourself out of cancer
but you can't call it early in the
stages but later on you can
they keep going so it's Admiral
physiology where does the animal
physiology come from we're gonna reason
our way through genetics genetics is it
strictly genetic yes life's to genetics
and environment interact to give you an
admirable set of cell biology right
right okay and that cell by how do I
know that cell biology is going on the
abnormal biology the pathophysiology how
do I know that happens I'm a convenient
you can because they're symptoms signs
and symptoms there's signs and symptoms
so if somebody like me comes in it goes
those signs of symptoms mean
pathophysiology here mean let's look at
his genes let's look at his environment
see how that Kurt what are those signs
and symptoms do over time and breakdown
they progressed were they resolved or
they become chronic they have they have
a what's called a natural history and
then what does somebody like me try to
do with natural history well you you try
to alter it you try to alter we try to
treat it we do treatment so a disease is
a complex relationship between the
substrate and the environment that
results in a an abnormal state of
physiology reflected in signs and
symptoms that follow a predictable
pattern we call a natural history with a
predictable response to treatment well
the diction fits that model perfect a
channel when people freak out as whereas
the cancer it's in your brain the cells
are abnormally functioning in your brain
the pathophysiology is there and we know
a lot about it now and it's some of its
chronic some of it doesn't get better
and so it's always there loaded up ready
to go if you recall and so and it goes
and once you have real addiction I mean
bonafide addiction volition has nothing
to do with you can't choose anything so
that's not sure is it not treatable at a
certain it's treatable but you have to
get somebody in a place where they can't
use their volition we're there there
where they start to understand that any
thought any impulse any any but we call
stinking thinking any desire I have is
my disease because it might all the all
the wonderful functions we have rational
prefrontal and all stuff alls under the
influence of distorted motivation which
is as opposed to survive and thrive and
protect your family its use that becomes
your sole motivation and that's a broken
state of brain but can I get back back
to we were
BIRT talk about let's talk about bird
well I was talking about bird but I
don't want to like you know - yeah -
bird no but my question about someone
like him is like isn't there like people
with will use him as an example who like
he's a late-night guy he likes to have
fun he you know he can party drink a
bunch but then he can also yes he does
not have a what we would call a high
biological genetic burden right okay
there's some people they they start and
kaboom you go I'm reading this book on
Grant grant had real-deal alcoholism he
was like Andy Dick okay real deal when
he would drink he would just go all the
way to Matt every time every time and he
could not he couldn't do anything about
there are grades to this there are
different biologists to it and there's
grades to it was it yes it but he could
be I mean said you can all end up in the
same place it's not bad sober can go I'm
saying burr could go south but he could
also be fine right yeah he can live his
whole life like this
he can stay at this level for his whole
life he could sure doesn't have to
progress particularly takes periods of
abstinence and stuff like and he felt
good during that absence oh great and it
was reinforcing to him so he might have
more periods like that yeah yeah he felt
great yeah I mean I think it was healthy
for everybody I even Joe Rogan was
talking about how he felt better yeah
not smoking pot which is like yes dude
you can't take them mind altering or
brain affected substance every day and
not have it affect something yeah plus
we thought we did a bunch of hot yoga
classes so that also made us feel good
good you know we did 15 in a month
good 90-minute class right yeah yes
legend Jose a think tanks but I mean
like it was it was a fun it was its I
think exercises and discipline are just
healthy so they even if you are not
somebody that goes like let's say you
don't like it wasn't hard for me to not
drink for a month but it's still an
exercise in in discipline so I enjoy
challenges yeah it is but I push back a
little bit against thinking about people
that consume excess alcohol is not being
disciplined because some of the most
disciplined people I know can still have
a problem over here with the alcohol
again I'm thinking of grant and grant
stuff sure super discipline but man if
he got exposed yeah watch
yeah so anyway Danny was spend long
periods of time he was committed to the
essentially early a a which were the
temperance movements he actually signed
temperance agreements instead because he
knew he knew what he's dealing with yeah
and it's funny when people have the real
deal alcoholism they know they don't
they know exactly what's going on yeah
we think's going on here just from drugs
delusional delusional mental illness
well let's go through daily analyze the
here's a day he was not having our guys
he was pretending to her yeah she might
have been having an orgasm I don't know
how she got there he might have holding
a vibrator or something everything knows
but first of all we need to teach them
both how to look into a camera yeah
looking off camera like that yeah and
it's not like they're bringing everybody
somewhere they're way off camera and
then they're in a like a convention
center has been some sort of tantric sex
meeting of switches gross but he looks
very happy that they're there yeah she
looks full of shit basically and they
have bullshit stare yes to me it's just
bullshit so I he's just happy to be
there he's like yes yeah he just wants
to get laid that's right if you find a
path to get laid and like you hadn't
been laid in a while yeah but that's
really what's happening is she's into it
and then he's just using this way yeah
so she's delusional right about this
horseshit is it just to get attention is
that is that what we're doing at the
calm hugs I am guessing that again it's
some sort of weird gathering you know
thing and the wave is her friend that
runs it and she's just a good example of
our friends or maybe she runs it maybe
she's trying
commercial it feels like a scam to me
too and the other thing is like you draw
people then you get attention
yeah people sign up and then they're
like I keep hugging I'm not coming
though what's going on they're like you
feel like you're not doing it right you
got paid for another another side
another another conference yeah or you
start through the perfect scam and these
are blaming yourself
pretend that you're coming oh then you
are part of the delusion the delusion
yeah I came I mean look at this fucking
coming yeah look at his face he's crack
it out and he's like really you know
he's this his neck muscles contraction
is laughing yeah it's a little bullshit
yeah it's so yeah we can't have three of
us kind of standard if somebody else is
happy I don't like it either it bothers
me when people can get joyful about
things like that I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this okay I can't wait like
guys who love to fucking fuck good if
you're a hot black guy you want to fuck
me only 95 if you want to move in you
can move in fuck me I mean I need you
fucked a lot man yeah we got it for free
food free wrench and everything else man
he has a deal man jail homeless Orem
you're a thug want to come move in a
friend come with you man free rent at
least in a cage
fuck me piss somebody beat me at home
you know you see me when I come over
today and try it out try it out man yeah
dark the circles are rasterize well I
was drunk I slept in a month and then I
just smell math I can smell bad yeah
well the first time we play is
interesting I said you know if anything
about this you play this over and over
again oh yeah this is a regular cliff
[Music]
now forget it
we're ruined I'm gonna bring up my
question but this I was like you know
some part of every man's brain that has
wanted to like express these feel like a
but this is fuck me but I'm saying yeah
for someone to actually pull out a
camera and going to be this just
disconnected and all of it
this was somebody was like severely
beaten as a child yeah it's just all I
see is just abuse abuse because he's
right oh he's reenacting the trauma to
try to solve it or whatever whatever our
brain does let's do that that's
interesting so what's with the ball on
his head that's well that's not just a B
G there that's just it's very dark it's
not well it he's shirtless made this sad
for me now and yeah it is that's why I
could never go to strip clubs and things
ya know it's empowering don't you know
it's suppose to be empowering yeah
that's what they said it is you guys
don't get it um so yeah my bills and
tried out looks like a piss let me try
it out apply Tony is fuck man I'm
looking for hard crooked eyes I mean it
want to do it and I want to deliver it
I'm a hot fuck my trash you're fine buck
people just send this into it so that's
nice yeah I'm so glad talking to your
fan to give me one one what do they call
it
101 one deal with the big level football
division one don't give you division one
just high school I'm so glad you're here
because I we get these clips and we just
we laugh at them I I laugh at oh but we
cuz you know what's happening and
nothing
you know I get to see this you know with
the door shut
yeah it's definitely deeply troubling
well you know III told I told her this
before every time I you know I've met
porn stars immediately like I don't see
them as sexual beings right like you
because you you make it you get what's
going on yeah so I go I mean I totally
understand did you see the sex rehab
sure we did I saw yes so Jenny Ketchum
penny flame penny flame I remember her
yeah yeah
just graduate from social work as an MSW
at University of Washington fantastic
you're getting a PhD she's amazing Wow
good she's are getting married pregnant
[Music]
I asked only if it's like like a public
thing I always seem that trying about
about the patients yeah about about her
and this okay yeah I'm saying if it's
not known or yeah public yeah yeah I
can't tell you if it's not right but
like so was she traumatized
oh yeah really we talked about Oh
everyone's trauma came out on the show
but for some reason it people either
didn't watch it or didn't get amplified
they were specified enough I mean like
Jeff Conway's trauma was so profound so
unbelievable and ritualistic and people
are like when it was around Jeff it's
like you didn't hear him talking about
he was dragged into his child porn ring
and he was beaten by them airing that
yeah every one of them I don't treat me
I always tell people if you up bad
enough addictions you need to see me as
a hundred percent probability of
childhood trauma really yeah a hundred
percent I'm not saying that all
addiction as childhood trauma I'm saying
if it's bad enough that you need to come
to somebody like me is to this childhood
trauma and it's bad well Jenni a
horrible stuff well that's what I
learned watching
Celebrity Rehab I think that's what
right when I started getting a therapy
is there was that trend of I mean we
discussed this on your podcast when the
person would go in and drew be like hell
is your childhood that's fine yeah great
oh yeah oh except for the part that my
dad beat the shit out of me and my mom
no I I'd have to go I'd have to go I'd
have to go well do you have any physical
abuse off no I go I go did anybody ever
discipline you
well like anybody alright and then I go
okay got discipline so they hit you yes
of course I did
everybody like anybody I need it I go
did anybody ever pick up an object and
hit you fight belts and did they use the
buckle and yeah of course the bar closed
one time was a bat only on the hatchet
oh yeah in the bow and arrow you know
and then the judge and they think of
that as normative and they needed it
that's how they get it they internalize
it like I was serving at that which is
which is the child feels so powerless
that they flip it into uncaused this I'm
making this happen to me because I need
it because I'm bad that's because mom
and daddy can't be bad yes I need them
sure that's right and what happens is
those unresolved feelings of trauma turn
into night like you just said sometimes
addiction sometimes they manifest what
later in life is something but can be
treated yes right right that's the big
highlight of this don't tell us
something specific no I mean I just want
people to feel I don't want to feel
hopeless listening oh shit I was hit and
I screwed fundamentally the way I think
about the simplest way I look at it is
that it you need closeness of other
humans to develop the mechanism for
emotional regulation that emotions if
you've been traumatized or to TRO
prolonged to intense and to negative and
the way that is healed is in closest
with another human unfortunately when
you've been traumatized
you don't trust other humans anymore and
you exit the frame of closeness and you
never go back until somebody in therapy
finds their way back in with you and
that person then holds that frame and
just listens to you and reacts how hard
is it because this is one of the things
I think maybe I don't know that a lot of
like the amateur audience watching a
show like that would would have
difficulty processing is the the level
of distrust from some of the people that
you're treating although I feel like
though like aren't they isn't it hard to
break down yes
truth that's from this it it turns me
into a gigantic mind reader it does yeah
I got to the point I'm a little out of
practice with it right now but where I
could I could just trust whatever came
out of my mouth without thinking about
it you can trust whatever comes I but I
could when I was really skilled at this
I'm a little bit rusty right now but but
I would just I would I would do what's
called I would listen with my whole body
I would not listen to what they're
saying because I know what they're
saying is all
shit and I would just listen the whole
bunny if I felt something or heard
something or smelled something I would
immediately go immediately go hang on
I'm just I'm not sure if does this have
meaning to you I was feeling like oh yo
that's my dad was always making bacon
when he'd fucking throw grease on me and
burn me I like okay well I just happen
to smell some bacon oh man Wow it's all
compartmentalised and I'm literally
picking up on disavowed disconnected
parts of the self that are crying out
for attention but are disconnected from
that human consciously but it's there
all the time creating all kinds of
emotional turmoil in that person and I
sort of they sort of hey they pick it up
when it be like that Freud thing of your
unconscious reading another person's yes
that's what is it but I but I think I
think it's that sort of a it's not a
evolved enough way of thinking about I
really feel like that there's so much
information going back and forth between
two bodies in proximity it's really not
just the brain it's our entire central
nervous system including our autonomic
system and we just we just can we send
stuff back and forth to people if you
really listen if you learn to really
train yourself and I also train myself
to be able to know when people were not
talking it through then I would just go
that's very nice but you're full of shit
stop it please
and I could just trust it when I would
come out of my mouth and most of the
time most the time they would go how'd
you know yeah and they'd go I don't even
know when I bullshitting anymore but I'm
glad you helped me I need to know what
I'm you must have worked with some
master manipulator oh my god and I've
been manipulated and I've been had and
whatever but but you but but I can if I
do feel it I can just go man
yeah we're gonna be or not shut up it
reminds me of by the way this I mean to
say the skillset you're talking about is
watching like detectives interrogate
yeah different and then you see like we
used to watch a lot of the first 48 and
there's there is certain detectives that
that was the hook of like that was you
get excited about like she is amazing
there's something right on she would
yeah sergeant Mason I think in in
Tennessee I still remember her name and
she would go in and the guy be like I
didn't you know I didn't
do anything I wasn't there and she had
this ability to connect yeah and five
minutes later you just see and then they
would confess yeah it was amazing did
you see mine hunter yes i watch you got
some of that stuff came out in that - oh
yeah same idea yeah yeah fantastic Ember
even when he met that first guy who's
like oh they well how'd you feel about
it it didn't feel right well there you
go listen to that you're we're perfect
instruments we really are and if you've
been injured that perfection gets
expressed in crazy ways you know like
women that repeatedly go for abuse of
guys yeah if you're attracted to the guy
definitely that's gonna be an abusive
guy if you have that pattern you have
that pattern if you were abused as a
child and you have that a pair of adult
and you won't you think that's a great
guy guaranteed that guy's gonna be I
know he looks nothing like an axe
nothing like the other ones yeah still
that's gonna be something that like I've
been you know we've all have
interactions with like bad dudes you
feel it you feel yeah
site like predator dudes you know I mean
guys you're like this doesn't feel right
right away yeah I feel like sometimes
you can I don't know it could be out in
public you could be introduced to
someone you'll be like I don't know
anything creepers man yeah good times
huh yeah videos the women practice on
the egg what did the men do okay the man
the first thing they have to practicing
they recall sharpening the knife okay
the hokies way simple you get a toy
recorder egg the baby oil any oil okay
and you put it in and now you Joe the
peanuts the warm evening in the cold
winter you warm them up you get hot
power okay and you make it a warm the
work the hand just put your hands make
sure all the blood flow okay on your
penis
okay now you get the penis out yeah you
put the skin a lot of people they never
circum for skin oil in hand and your
right hand corner a few rough rough
rough rough especially on the Klan penis
rub them fifty time wrasse
okay because you make them strong and
not sensitive to the time once one rice
I fifty time left side
from fifty time back with become now
what three feel okay how often am I
doing this you have to do every day
until you can control every day
time-consuming extremely sort of I'm
opening the knife okay all right if you
don't traveling tonight there's the
number one number two you have to learn
how to contracting the process know when
many calculation the pressure of the
ejaculation
if form the process again contracting
okay so exercise in the exercise okay
and for people have posted plans to own
a knob a problem this one who solved the
problem and now you do it until you feel
orgasm oh really yes okay call orgasm
without ejaculation right yeah so you
feel so you see when you do when when
you get it it's very quick to to time
you can you squeezed all guess I'm
coming up he's a teacher he's a tantric
guy he's a lot of things actually what
else well he he also teaches women you
know to rub their nipples and I think
your vagina muscles are loose then in
there your door is opened and all the
energy leaks out of your vagina she
reminds you yoga guy the tantric a
minute like we we after we this was the
first thing we were exposed to about him
and then we found what's his if this guy
can't figure what do you think he's tai
tai yeah and then then he did like a
female one in the same interview and
then somebody found like a twenty five
thirty five-year-old clip of him he's
been doing way you know this is like
your kidneys expected to testicles you
got rub your back like this so what you
said that's not right when you said the
orgasm isn't your prostate is imperfect
floor musculature contracts but that's
not doing your prostate and and the the
seminal vesicles are what are holding
the semen the prostate is just a gland
that's sort of slowly producing
fluid and story of the seminal vesicles
it's not really
any other activity and what about
sharpening the knife is that an
effective times rub rub rub I think the
whole point of this was about control
yes yes and that's what it sounds there
a tantric like yeah but then I'm like
three no time three strokes and all I
kept thinking was three hundreds of
targets about 600 seconds or so who the
fuck has time to do this and every day
and I'm worried about that person's soul
again weird about the souls of all these
people that you're showing me because
their priorities don't seem right if
that's what their product if I was doing
everyday this better mindfulness then
sharpening the knife seemed better
mindful practice there's a possibility
that this guy is a bit delusional though
has no I don't think this guy's mentally
ill I don't think you don't think yes no
I just think it's a weird thing is evil
bad weirdo that they exist
oh I'll raise you and like they are
getting turned into lasagna so I didn't
need your help getting a rescue boat
over there and they they really need
your help getting rescued so could you
really please please talking to Hitler
she's vlogging to Hitler she's asking
the fear she's asking him for a rescue
boat two friends were returned to the
scampi Gabby boat they're turning into
lasagna okay so what Hitler is the guy
she's talking she sings happy birthday
and again I I owe a leader of the third
I always like to look at the environment
look at all that well she's a really big
fan of that one direction yeah reminds
me of people that set up you know sort
of shrines
yes the people they're gonna try to
murder them it looks like that kind of
thing yeah and when you could you close
your eyes and don't look at evading
listen to her voice she sounds like
she's about six years old would you
which is an interesting thing that
happens in severe trauma survivors is
they their voice and the sex stuff
second maybe we should have a new title
for our and if no will that feel better
now if and if she's not just sort of
being bullshitting she's severely
psychotic when you close your eyes one
second
close your eyes hmm and now what I
thought she said hey healer Oh so
severely psychotic yeah because of the
eyes and no I don't see any air phaser
is just what she's talking about
oh so disorganized and almost it almost
sounds you know delirious like she's
like well why don't we lighten things up
a little
oh yeah varsity level or just wanna see
your thoughts on this not somebody
talking but just to see like what you
find funny what you don't find funny and
see your reaction and then maybe you can
he's gonna he's gonna zoom right through
there no he's just setting the car up
[Music]
it's funny except I know what that
injury is that's bad that kind of a
crush injury is really bad I mean it's
funny but it's not funny thank you okay
so let us clue you in I want the debate
I mean crush injuries like that those
are common and they they unclog the low
it's just the worst so what had worked
often the leg will just split open and
unloved and tear the skin comes off
entirely and then depending on how bad
the crush is you know whether or not
their kidneys fail because their muscles
crushed and going into their blood
system and how about the blood supply is
cut off and how much orthopedic injury
there is there yeah it's just
those are catastrophes I have people
often die get amputees right and that's
really funny right calm no let's be fair
about something so I've always had and
I've admitted to it I think the way I
deal with with physical injuries you
laugh I laugh yeah four-thirty it's um I
think it's a red flag to me remember
Sasha and this'll be real yes Sasha
would laugh in the most horrible
situations she was all of a sudden start
giggling yeah there's nothing she could
do about it she was a great nurse and
really compassionate yes but she had
this weird yeah nervous thing when when
things got really rough and say you know
terrible things started happening she
freaked out like Oh laughter but why
does my husband find that clip so funny
when people like thank you because I've
watched the clip several times and we've
had other guests on and I can't laugh
because I had left said how fun unit I
have what's called empathy
funny if it were the Three Stooges the
whole problem is it's one thing that
bothers me about physical slapstick
humor is it you you believe that that's
just funny funny funny mild head
injuries fuck people up for six months
yeah yeah what one of Moe's you know
just the fingers in the eyes yeah of
course one of Moe's Blanc's on the head
would be six months of trouble and
and I and it's it is funny when it's the
Three Stooges or Laurel and Hardy when
it's fake in this case what's funny also
is that his reaction I think also
because it's foreign like that you know
you don't understand what he's saying
yeah you could you can be there's some
distance you can get from you get
distance from it it's a it's an almost
comical reaction yes was like oh my god
that's funny and that's like oh my god
that's really opinion pinning pinning
against the wall I remember when I
worked I worked construction one summer
in high school and this guy had a sown
in like morphine drip pack for his neck
that's bullshit and and I was like worse
I go like why do you have that and he
started telling me like very seriously
he was on this site and they were
removing a bathtub from the third floor
and it it fell out from the lift and it
crushed his neck I laughed so so hard us
to love that well he was just looking at
me and then he got he realized that he
started telling me all these other
injury stories and then he got to the
point where he'd be like I just
remembered you're gonna love this one so
he would do it to entertain me like one
time I was on the site and I broke my
arm doing this and I I've always found
that's how I process how bring the guy
around with you all the time you need to
levity go I mean it just just I don't
know why keep the good times right
you should be coming to orthopedist you
would never stop laugh wait so why do we
do that because I laugh at things that
are inappropriate as well is it well
you're now you're asking me what's the
nature of humor and laughter which is a
really complicated question but his his
reaction to that man hurting being
harmed and possibly dying is his
laughter and that is number I said evil
exists on the spectrum I'm not sure it's
that kind of problem but no and what
about this dream on something's really
wrong with me
yes he's dark dark sighted dorks I don't
know what about the fact that my husband
okay I'm incredibly compassionate uh-huh
okay when I'm falling asleep at night
he'll watch TV and he'll watch it's a if
you look at his Netflix queue it's
murder murder
psychopath serial killer drew they make
all those shows just for me yeah isn't
that neat yeah they go like really deep
into production for me we'll talk later
I've talked them they've said was just
free on orders just for me all that
starts 48 it's just all me likes that
should I be concerned I think I gotta go
now but he's such a gentle soul yeah the
thing is he would never hurt a fly so
yeah exactly what you do as a kid were
you twisting rabbits necks and I can
call the people home I do it now see if
I can really stalk you know pick someone
and I go following you oh my god
yeah get to know their habits with a
little work okay anyways anyways here's
another one that's not like those other
ones I swear please but I really want
your opinion on this and then he didn't
want my opinion all the other one no no
I did this is interesting one I think
seriously Sweden is the most
forward-thinking country in the world
when it comes to questioning gender the
gender neutral pronoun hen is now
commonly used by most Swedes so that's
just a little Intel beginning beginning
this is Niko's room and holders Niko
because two and a half a meter it's
almost five in half mica and Nico were
both assigned male at birth but in this
family the sexy were born with does not
dictate your gender identity so then so
we're giving you just little context for
this we use he for them sometimes it's
mixed and it depends you know because in
Sweden we have hen the gender-neutral
pronoun in Swedish I think Mika has
always said when I've asked it's been
she or kin of changing pronouns in book
instead of it always being mama we say
mama and mapa what's the matter sweetie
access mapa it's so dark
so just to give you the full thing the
next clip is also i want you to weigh in
on there's this family there in sweden
you understand that
they were talking about the pronouns
and then these very young kids are being
created they're getting different
hormones
no they're just daily being given the
option o to choose pronouns and it's
switch two and a half and five year olds
are there they're being asked hey what
would you like me to call you today
that's not something I always have to
save it it would be good to know today
through the film
this guy is a horn and ahem just Miko
okay so the kid answered just my name
yes those do you think that there's
anything odd to asking very small
children their gender pronouns
I don't know cuz it way it's it's
unusual we're not used to that but I
would have to be really study have to
see what the outcomes are hi I'm a
little concerned with the biological
reassignments the president of
Pediatrics just came out strongly
against it is that being done oh yeah
wait what do you mean reassignment
they're like they're being if they say I
feel like a girl today Franco and I even
though a boy you better get on those
hormones right away keep the
three-year-old and that's concerning and
we don't even know the full medical
consequence to that either yet so it's
all that people are doing that oh yeah
like crazy but but I did this part I am
surviving agnostic about yeah it's like
it's like maybe I don't know yeah okay
I'm more worried with the way this guy's
treating his children that does not feel
very connected or empathic yeah this
feels very tutorial everything's very
like weird and formal but baby it's just
cuz the cameras there I don't write
right oh my could be yeah but it would
not feel comfortable being his was he
dad or mom well he's mom you would not
feel comfortable having him as my part
right she's like hey shut up coming
Becca yeah stop asking me do you think
the league mental is going on with this
type I'm don't understand like why you
and people is mad just because I sound
black and that's what I can say I'm
black right at the end of the day what
is a race anyways you family could like
we all want we all here on this world
supposed to be equal it's just in the
past people was messed up and stuff oh
honey yeah what's going on here
I feel so angry at our educational
system sometimes yeah I really get angry
I don't see anything
mental nothing mental health wise other
than little angry but but just like come
on everybody
yeah yes go back to school the field
function of society yeah fuck Beach why
would you somebody you don't know and
obviously you pussy I'm not ugly bitch
in my hair go down might be a little bit
never claimed to be standing is there
for people just listening these are two
back-to-back white girls I love these
two girls yeah they're pretty and pretty
entertaining why don't you start talking
like that I'm trying I can't do the
accent that you know he'll talk about
being raised around that oh really oh
yeah yeah he does not have good feeling
he surprised what was going on there
really yeah yeah she's crazy that's
pretty good gonna give me trouble
without um what's the racial stuff Tommy
what's that word you taught me where you
choose your race trans Ranger that's
interest that's people are like saying
like like it'd be like me saying you
know because I was born I know but you
see but I'm actually Filipino yeah
identify with Filipino on this or is
that uh what's going on
try to get me how much trouble you try
to get me a big one podcast curious
about these people what's happening is
this a societal thing yeah this is a
social phenomena this is not this is not
a real health issue okay
got you so this is just the times this
is this is what's in the ethers like I'm
oh I'm doing that thing - yes okay
interesting cuz yeah if you wanna move
oh oh there's one last guy this guy's
been like this poor man right but
there's just one guy we want you to
weigh in on all right just he just he's
got a dinner waiting for him to come
walking down the street just working on
a song okay
she's worth a machine to us then they've
got a gun I got again yeah I got a gun
terminating a gun yeah machines but then
machines were thin g60 you notice
anything there is everything seemed
normal or no
well I rank my rep trying to make my rep
Chum talk to so I'm with flow trial
practice on my foot machines width in
machine I feel sad it makes me sad what
well part of it
just that we're failing people so
miserably crazy isn't it well drop that
bursary for you crazy isn't easy isn't
it drop that first drop that first got
the knife crazy isn't it
got that knife crazy isn't it crazy
isn't fucked up first how crazy isn't it
innocence yes this guy's great
Juggalo yes okay he would he'll be fine
there he'll be fine amongst his peers
there it is normative somewhat normative
behavior he's engaged even the Juggalos
will fight fraught with this but he will
he like a good Juggalo okay amazing you
got your spidey senses back so now would
you say this is mental illness or an
educational failure this juggle OSIS I
was almost went to the Juggalo convent
where they call it The Gathering yeah I
want to go to gathering just to see
what's what's going on there and I gotta
show you so many people that's so
interesting want you to treat them my
very favorite can you treat them and
masks can you open up a booth at the
juggle okay well the price did people
warned me off going cuz they said it'd
be too scary that I would get hurt I
think that's a good I that's a good
really wanted to go though I really did
so but this gentleman is just he's a
Juggalo it's just it's a cultural yeah
no pressure no problems okay he's not
angry oh yeah
he's socially like I said I got sad but
to know there's a place a home even for
him amongst the Juggalos I mean that
felt pretty good another one I'm in love
with good comedy man well I'm saying
like is there anything to doing that
is there like should I be concerned
about her well that's trauma right you
know fart videos yeah the money come on
for money she gets paid for that of
course yeah god is great
I mean seriously like seriously I mean
there's people that do this is there
something that people that then play it
over and over again to other guests on
par you're saying I'm just saying I'm
just saying she's been abused right yeah
she's a very sweet girl this is the best
thing ever this is now that's just funny
I just enjoy that thank you what about I
mean party what why is that funny
because it's it's because this type of
because you have so like there's so many
tells that you're keyed in on yeah I
like cuz you're like you know you look
at the I yeah yeah do you think that
this voidable property yeah like to do
copious amounts of cocaine with her to
the point and when I thought my heart
was gonna stop yeah that's it she made
me do copious amounts of cocaine with
her to the point I thought my heart was
gonna stop that did she told me to calm
down
so gave me a drink and I don't know I
was in the drink but I blacked out look
up she had both my legs over her
shoulders and she was numb sucking my
asshole like there is no tomorrow
what I'm sucking I tried to fight it I
tried to get away but I was restrained
she told me that I liked it you probably
told me not to worry cuz she is the good
jelly the schmucker's I mean is there
something we don't know nobody's paid me
to confess this now and I've kept it
under wraps for all these years because
I knew that no one would believe me
Hillary Clinton telling the truth I
can't tell I can't tell please not
telling the truth I don't what's up with
him the truth Ryan Sickler very funny oh
is it no no I thought it was him looking
for my favorite picture here for you
guys on the Juggalos yes might check a
little picture I'm gonna find they could
really use you in that community yeah
maybe I just don't want them to kill me
if I show up no we've had a bit of a
rest time now facin seems really simple
but this
let's hat just github play pub landing
around and gone wolf wolf or bok-bok but
it's really so much more complicated
that guy started this pup play training
in New Zealand raining training and he's
got all these guys into it there and he
was basically like oh it's a fun
get-together you know first he was like
just a bunch of guys yeah enjoying each
other's company and then later it's like
we also ejaculate in each other's faces
yeah big secret so that's sort of like
the Furbys furries yes on that video
there it's all like you know on the up
like it's like we just hang out and I
treat them like dogs and then we found
videos of him online in a different
light where he was basically like run
your finger along a crack if you Ross
you don't need to figure your whole you
don't want to come back with shit on
your finger no you don't want that yeah
but he was instructing people in a much
more graphic way when it wasn't for a
news piece works he didn't want to yeah
what's that there we go oh my god he and
violent Jay and Shaggy so drew show me a
picture tonight on Loveline you had
these two guys on level repeatable the
Insane Clown Posse these guys many times
I see Peter my buddies there I've heard
them on a stern before they yes they
seem fun they're late or something out
funny guys like come to studio like this
they never are seen anywhere without
either a Mexican wrestling mask mask or
that a comic upon ever they've never
been saying a lot of work that does seem
like a lot of work yeah do they do it
themselves now imagine the guy with the
hockey mask wearing that makeup that
starts to make sense doesn't it right
right right
what's your take on you would look like
shaggy you know people make fun of
Juggalos a lot and like I see Peter
stuff but then I'll also bring about how
business savvy these guys are with this
you know they're brilliant and they're
there's a whole philosophy and stuff and
you gets hard to argue with them ever
they really are crediting guys yeah and
it is positive right they're all about
there's a little bit too much aggression
of violence when they gather but but
other than that I have no quarrels
all right well we'll look we want you to
go home and have salmon and I want to
seize one fart videos I mean really
we got them you asked for it yeah Oh
same girl no do you think do you think
she really does this or somebody's
playing with a video there's a rooster
in the background you know who you not
sure that was the best idea do you think
people pay for this yeah that's the
thing that we're trying to figure out is
it sexual yes yes it's so they could get
off on this it's not just common first
write it up a while ago a guy wrote in
he was like well the whole thing is
seeing a pretty girl do the dirty thing
that's what he gets off on a dirty thing
well you know why the rest of us just
laughs let me see if I think this girl
definitely had a bad child
I mean you don't fart on the internet
because things were good in your
childhood you know there's there's a
high degree of secondary reinforcement
what's happening she gets paid a lot
probably to do yeah may just be one of
those things do you want a hundred
dollars I think Susan says she's tired
and she made a crappy dinner
Oh gonna be like I'm glad I'm not there
should I put her on the shade get on the
phone yeah tell her we're watching fart
videos do you think something's going on
we're going to show you the king real
quick sorry sorry sorry
please analyze this guy we're really
curious about him oh yeah just texted me
what chance photos drives me crazy
drives me crazy don't you want to murder
your spouse sometime no I want to kill
you when you don't answer and I want to
talk to you but you didn't justice
complete a text to you I cannot answer
oh my god please come on come on Susan
come on she's missing such good material
talk about she loves fart humor real
really no she does not get it at all do
you fart in front of each other
[Music]
he's called King ass River I put that
guy in Stern that does Joe the fart yes
blows that guy away dude yeah it's
really says the real thing we've tried
contacting him Allah oh my god he won't
come on our show I know I guess his
identity is a secret
yeah yeah in this video does he respond
to your email no I mean look look we've
offered him money look it's all about oh
my god yeah you guys live in this world
yeah yeah hi Susan you're on the podcast
you didn't tell me that hey you didn't
tell me that your mom's house is just
these two sitting are watching right
babe okay look at the King on the voice
she's watching The Voice oh wait you
didn't tell me that your mom said hang
on you didn't tell me your mom's house
is just these two sitting around
watching fart videos which no we have
file saved we yes how did you how did
you know about that
well these two have made an art form of
that they apparently study it like this
a brooder tape yeah yes I was my first
exposure was recently yes we're both
like in disbelief of cake farts no this
was just watching women for it online
yeah what especially thankfully I'd been
pre my my hymen had been ruptured prior
to getting here I might have been shot
so many but I just want to tell you I'm
here that but she can't hear it yeah of
course but the dog enjoys it is it
really considered animal abuse Susan I
called you to tell you what I'm still
doing so I will get home as soon as I
can Dedra crappy dinner as you said it's
fine I'm sure we miss you Susan we wish
you to be here they miss you we missed
you I'm sad you didn't come wait wait
I'm sorry Susan how great how great is
Drew's body
yeah yeah that must be nice give all the
plugs I'm not sure you want this crowd
over there but no no not these two I
mean the people they find them amusing
[Music]
okay all right and soon enough bye
by and I just did it's beautiful yeah
the your show what's it called sorry I
forgot what the hell just crank him out
do you like a pro podcaster yeah I'm
like it was a serious workaholic though
so everything seems easy to me since
this yeah this is the farter he also
does gluttony videos 3 fucking beef and
cheddar sandwiches slop with fucking
mayonnaise he's in Brooklyn - yeah I
don't like the eating no hard to watch
yeah but he but I love how fucked up
people are that they weird there's a
there's also videos or he gets out a
bunch of this food and farts on it and
then he says I wanna I would I'm not
interested in him I'm interested who's
watching him yeah we've brought him to a
lot of people I mean a lot yeah yeah
thanks you're gonna throw up do you
think this is like a fetish thing yes oh
this is all finished
anything that's sexual that shouldn't be
sexual yeah why why do you think
gluttony i-i've I don't not an expert in
this area but I've always had the sense
that it was something to do with being
force-fed as a child or something then
it was too gratifying or maybe the
breastfeeding was done into an
aggressive away or something so they
always feel like they're overwhelmed by
it yeah just do fart videos and then
then he started doing the evolved as an
artist yeah he really did evolve but I
paid for these things right I think so
but you know we've never really found
his voice done more fucking gluttony I'm
wondering if it's my channel gluttonous
slob and go to the pig out check out but
there's no women that are interested no
no I mother heterosexual mez all
everything where does mad let's face
yeah that's why he won't answer us genes
I think we cut we've reached out to him
so many times and I think he needs to
keep his business intact
I think it's gay guys yeah he goes also
by I fart in yo face
that's uh but he we really this is him
here this is like him it is hard dresser
to fart on you know and he would just
post these videos
nice nice good a jackhammer quaffing or
another you know there's a big scandal
about those fart videos with him was
that Pete handle but people didn't
believe they were genuine he was
shooting air into himself okay well yeah
well let me ask you this medically
speaking I mean is that really possible
what that guys doing or is that fake
it's possible is that the bacteria can
produce a lot of gas right they solute
that I tried to do are you writing this
down
and so the methane that's produced by
the bacteria can be high volume and if
he holds it in for periods of time and
then films it when it's time to go yeah
I can see Robbie probably knows what to
give him feed himself to get the optimal
and sometimes swallowing air sometimes
people small out of air and some of the
guys can suck in air yeah they can
actually it's kind of a trick a parlor
just not a real thing like inserting air
well let's be fair what is it you
actually want from this guy I mean does
it really matter how it got to that
point does that violate your
sensibilities your delicate
sensibilities the Geneva Convention on
fart production has to be pure bacterial
methane production will have no more air
from below the judges at-will rule for
me yes farts I want him to eat that
Arby's yeah but if it's swallowing air
as part of it his gas production some
people the air goes through yeah why not
give them that if he has that talent I
mean I understand like I'm just saying
what the judges say I feel like the
committee would want to review this well
I feel too worthy of worthy of throwing
the flag I want official review yeah I
have another very scientific oh my god
take anymore my mother used to tell me
she used to I used to fart a lot and
when sometimes I'd complain about the
farts she would say that you should be
grateful for the farts because farts
push the shit out now is that true that
farts push it up push the farts out
there's farts and shit or a scent or
sort of Diskin
acted phenomena yeah a little connected
but there obviously there's some
connection there but they they're
independent they're not like this don't
push the farts out they Eve a shit will
a fart will come out with the ship with
the system yeah and the she said the
farts pushed the shit a little different
and just come out they just forget no
causal relationship really I mean it may
give you more of a sense of studying and
being on did I ever think I'd be on this
show Annie show talking about this no
that's not something expected to be
talking about I thought we'd I thought
your wife was really smart Thomas
Aquinas
I care got Tom I took a leap of faith by
coming on this show and I'm here that
well yeah I was wrong so much workout
required to get here but I think
Heidegger was a little close to the
proper analysis of the extension thank
you so much thank you for letting us
torture you at this plant this is are we
really done I have a weird sort of like
desire to continue oh I thought the
weird like weird like I feel attached to
all this I'm traumatized I guess yeah be
traumatic attachment I love it
trauma bonding you're gonna see a beards
with this for a long time and it's
stalking behavior yeah and I'm not gonna
know when to leave or go give me one
more give you one more baby give me a
give me a high grade no violence a
medical injury stuff that I'm gonna be
thinking about okay the surgical suites
oh I don't know what about the dad
excitement the transcript what what
about what have your other guests have
extra had extraordinary reactions to
extraordinary well we've high-level
reactions to to guess that should be
able to take it it's this thing I don't
know is this one of them who I want one
there's so many
it did eventually meet Ken who shares
her sexual preference no so file yeah I
don't I'm doing it on the fly it's a
bomber what about the what about the
trans-canada highway no that's not weird
enough no you know my radio partner Mike
Catherwood sends me where it's tough all
the time he goes on the dark web and
he's very fascinated with dire people
that diarrhea on each other I I need to
connect on my cup they diarrhea on each
other can't really do it on each other
only one person gets to be the receiver
oh I see it's really awful and I was
literally vomit every time and he finds
great Glee and delight people have a
strong reaction to this though all right
here we go I'm your mom and you're my
son and I am falling in love with him oh
he said are you really I said yes I am
he's thinking no what I was scared let
you know too I am too
we're both consenting adults if if it
comes you know operated and there's a
woman I ended up interviewing several
times who was in recovery from this and
so she can talk about what the delusion
is like when you're in it and how people
get into that and how they get out of it
so you're saying because of the
separation the bond ways it's distorted
yeah it gets all fucked up
so maybe how do you develop a romantic
you don't see them as a maternal figure
it's just a way it's just all you get
sexualized inappropriately as though so
should you be able to marry your mom no
because because whenever just like the
gays though that's what I saw that but
it's just like the gays well you should
think yeah yeah it's like if we're both
adults consanguinity and producing kids
at that close right yeah do that
but I you know question government
overreach that we should get involved
with that at all yeah yeah no I heard in
college that you can have this
university okay hey lesser school yeah
and I I was told that you can have
offspring with your cousin that you
won't have you can with your siblings
are and with your mom but it but the
that risk of trouble is they're really
hot but lesser as you get further and
further away it's less our cousins is
not that big a risk right like royalty
used to marry the Egyptian royalty were
married they're kids
yeah yeah brothers and sisters and
things they did horrible that's nasty
7,000 128 and this is where I believe
with a 90% no mix that 95% chance that
this is in fact the very place where the
trans-canada paved its last section
Golden Spike was put in there and he's
but he's really good he really just let
the guy with the double rainbows yeah we
never thought of no why didn't we think
of drugs what what kind of drugs are we
talking about your trans-canada highway
it's odd I mean it's a lot can I take a
shower before I leave but it's oddly
mesmerizing yes all of us rise
fuck you guys are doing good
Tom hurry up is that Charlie Oh dirty
son of a-- come down later promote soup
it's just super moose soup
yeah she's looking she's watching this
boat race and the guy falls in the water
and then she goes from like you know
like you hear like fuck cuz she felt it
and to keep ask them to come over for
moose soup that she's got later for them
what do you what do you think she looks
like drew like just on the voice the
granny from Beverly Hillbillies that's
yeah pretty accurate yeah all right you
guys are doing good it's not the race
affirmative we get to see she blows them
all later in a different video my girl
or guy yeah it's great
no no Tom does she look like the granny
you know whatever yeah it's like no no
she does she'll - she doesn't know no
she looks she looks like she's a mess
kind of built yeah like she has evolved
alright I'm ready to go alright okay I'm
tapped out this has been awesome yeah
thanks I wish I'd had a clip to play
that would top everything I was trying
to you know give me a give me a winner
yeah hang a stripper I mean I'm actually
pretty amazed at how not phase you are
by all this I mean you have seen it all
I have seen it all trust me mostly when
I write see aberrant behavior I am
either sort of zoo oddly you know sort
of intrigued or I feel sad yeah those
are the two feelings I get I like like
really people do that and then I get sad
because I know how you're sad but you're
also empathetic justice bright I think
we should go on strike against come
come strike keep going I'm going to
swallow the calm of a man or put on my
body to come of a man who's willing to
touch it or kiss me afterward she just
felt like she's good furniture plays a
little Chopin of Beethoven lady I won't
either bold dance she's my favorite
piano teacher yeah so it's a it's
extremely stuff people will put online
is that that's our whole show yeah yeah
but I mean the stuff and the stuff they
send you I'm impressed I'm I gotta get
Katharine and you're in here my radio
partner in in in your world let's do it
because he goes on a dark web and he's a
genius at finding horrible stuff oh
please hook us up okay yeah I have to
just constantly erase his text from
let's do a group just as a societal
question you're you're smart guy and you
seem to analyze stuff and where it's all
going I do feel like this lack of shame
that we're now experiencing in our
culture like people post income Strike
videos etc there used to be an element
of like hey this is private versus
public oh that's all going right what
are the consequences of that
psychologically as I a society I I'm
less worried about the the mechanism of
this manifesting as much as it is that
people are running at it and using it
all the time in other words they have no
personal boundaries so this is the
perfect place for them to be bound to
this it's not the technology's fault
that's enough Turtles yeah yeah I don't
know what you guys are putting online
but I'm gonna be looking I'm imagining
it's not gonna be this kind of stuff
yeah hoping yeah Tom's left no okay and
so it's you know we live in a time with
people have been abused their body
boundaries have been violated they have
no personal boundaries they've come from
no fan unstructured family systems and
you know that's this is it and shame is
shame is the sort of either they're
they're overcome by shame or they're
totally avoidant of shame
those are sort of the two versions we
have today an avoidant shame avoidance
our narcissist exactly Wow oh yeah the
artists refuse to feel ashamed of
anything yeah there's a really famous
guy right now we get to see him every
day
no but you know really was like that was
Clinton oh yeah it was very slippery
with shame and would just be you know
these horrible shameful things it's just
I mean narcissists who burn our system
and that I I'm surprised that has not
come crashing down more yeah so I feel
like there's a push for it more like
it's coming now it's just started a
comment and it's been I always thought
that was the most extraordinary
exploitation of what we have a bundling
you know just extraordinary yeah in a
place of business can you imagine the
person in the highest level of authority
take advantage of the person at the
lowest level yeah that guy would that
CEO would go to jail right not only
being a civil problem and if his wife
came at and and tried to abuse the
intern she'd be in trouble too it's like
it's not okay but I guess like we said
at the beginning to be a president you
can't be all that healthy yeah for sure
for the record drew thought that the car
crushed video was funny
so there's yeah I muted both of your
mics I muted both your mics yes he did
yes he did this is Tom signing off
you said it was funny I said there's a
funny Pete part of it to be very funny
if it were in the context of fiction a
lot of people sat there and said it was
funny by the way I understand why I
understand why but I know the reality
that those people are psychotic right no
no no no no I could see why somebody
would say that's funny see first of all
they were not female they were all male
mm-hmm which for sure right maybe we
find violence funny yeah women it's it's
also you know Three Stooges here because
they're dumber defining like Jim medow
ministry to does it's stupid because we
create life and you guys destroy it when
your mother and you make life the
thought is is pretty ridiculous little
something it'll kill we just destroy
name
it's my child I think honey go away to
your son gets older Oh God oh my god
you'll see it you will see it the
destructive nature
oh wait your kid turns 14 I can't wait I
want to be here to a podcast with you
you'll think it's you're coming back
then come back yeah yeah schedule it
let's schedule it alright thank you so
much thank you you know what that is
gene put those on it's a song made of
busy snores
[Music]
thank you for having me on
there you go